I'm a Democrat and so I will be voting
for the Democratic candidate this fall
and I think when you look at the far the
first of all both Democratic candidates
have excellent foreign policy advisors
and so I think in general their
positions are I think are well
thought-out and you know again I don't
agree with everything about them John
McCain is more complicated he you know
he takes it's hard to say who John
McCain is right now because he's he's
sort of morphing into some much more
right-wing version of himself which may
swing back again in the fall but John
McCain has also been advised by some
good people I think that's a good
example of something that's got to be
solved diplomatically and politically
after the fact you could have a treaty
that ratifies the agreement that's
struck but it's not something where it's
not a role for lawyers first and
foremost it's a role for political
leaders who can show vision and be
creative and bring together people that
are you know deeply opposed and I think
that's fundamentally a political process
I guess it depends on whose radar it is
I mean I think I think one of the really
big ones that has to be solved I
wouldn't say this isn't under the radar
issue but it hasn't gotten sufficient
attention is climate change and so you
know there's no question in my mind that
this is one of the most compelling and
and and deeply concerning issues out
there today and we're really grappling
with what to do and the US has to play a
leadership role right now we are facing
the question of what happens after the
Kyoto Protocol which was signed in 1997
that agreement essentially comes to an
end in 2012 so we're not that far away
and we need to have a much more
aggressive much more serious next
agreement that process has just begun
the key question I think will really be
will the u.s. play a leadership role or
will it continue to play the kind of
obstructionist role that it's played in
the past and I don't want to pin that on
the Bush administration which ministers
have been particularly bad but the
Clinton administration wasn't all that
great either so so what we need is real
leadership from the US if this issues
going to be tackled effectively I think
that's that's one of the major major
questions coming down